no one starts out completely successful  it's perceived as something easy  that it comes overnight every bit of  what i've learned  i want to share with you hey mark  what i'm doing is uh inciting  igniting the light that is inside of you  through my own experiences  if this were just a dance class you'd  only understand one level of it  what i'm giving you is the depth of what  it is to be an entertainer the depths  to go as far as you choose in life not  just as an entertainer  but as a person  from the moment that you walk on that  stage to the moment you have walked  backstage you have to be  committed i've had more failures than  i've had successes  take every opportunity to make yourself  better  allow the world's access to work for you  there's no new idea what is new  is your perspective of it what i want to  offer you is something that'll last  forever  now musher this is my master class  are you ready  [Music]  you